guys have trigger warnings gone like way
too far so I've always used trigger
warnings in my content because it just
kind of seemed like the progressive and
sensitive thing to do to try to respect
people's trauma and try to protect them
from harm but Recent research actually
suggests that trigger warnings may be
contributing to that harm so once I
found the trigger warnings increase the
extent to which people see trauma as
Central to their identity which can
actually be counter therapeutic because
it encourages avoidance and exacerbates
fear there's also a whole meta-analysis
looking at trigger warning outcomes that
found that presenting a trigger warning
actually had no effect on the emotional
response to those negative materials but
in a lot of cases it increased
anticipatory anxiety about the incoming
content it was also found that the
warnings either made people want to read
the content more or had no effect at all
so folks trigger warnings helpful or
harmful weigh in below